are you Tony's stank yes this is this is
Tony stank you're in the right place
thank you for that is there an Avengers
group chat yes there is who's the most
active probably Ruffalo
probably Mark what are you doing uh we
we don't do that here
[Music]
Hotel Rwanda
I knew nothing about what had happened
in Rwanda Terry George who directed it
reached out to me I read the script I
thought it was amazing he said to me in
my meeting very you know uh up front
like I need to get this movie made I
have to get the budget
um right now they're talking to me about
Will Smith or Cuba Gooding Jr and I'm
going to make this movie with whoever
gets me the the budget because it's a
story it's too important it needs to be
told and I said 100 I'm you know I would
love to help you produce it even if it's
not me who's going to get the role
because I agree this is a story that
needs to be told but ultimately the the
role came my way thankfully and I
started to dig into the research about
it I saw a Frontline piece about Rwanda
that Paul was in just you know learn
through Terry and also other members of
Paul's family and that's sort of how we
went into it when you're portraying a
real person you're trying to find where
your spirit and their Spirit kind of
meet and the things that you have to
take on from them and the things that
you have to bring that are of you to
them and you to it and somewhere in the
middle is where that the new you know
it's not you it's not him it's some
amalgamation of the two of you that
you're trying to find to just tell the
truth of the story and that's the most
important thing is to get to the truth
of it and to not do some sort of a an
imitation or an impression we were with
Paul a lot during the the filming of
that movie but he was a great resource
obviously which was
kind of intimidating to play somebody
who's you know sitting right there but
ultimately I was very glad to have him
there the whole time
we knew that after Paul came back from
that driving on that road that we needed
to have he needed to have a visceral
moment but we didn't know what it was
going to be or how it would be expressed
and so this went on for weeks and then
finally one day he said I think we have
to shoot it and I I said I think it
needs to be something just simple it
needs to be just simple I said well let
me just come back and see blood on the
tie and
we'll just shoot it in three scenes like
see me get the suit see him washing off
the blood and then see him tie the tie
and he can't tie the tie and something
very simple is that he can't tie the tie
takes him down and we did it and we shot
it twice and it was two takes and we I
think we used the first take it was not
scripted we just knew that something
needed to happen we had survivors that
were in the movie that were extras in
the movie just talking to them about the
realities of what had happened and their
experiences it's just yeah it's not it's
not just a movie you're walking back
into a traumatic traumatic moment in
history with these people who are still
dealing with it daily and will never be
over it so no it wasn't something that
you just put down and walk away so I
still talk to his family uh now that
movie sort of launched a lot of my own
personal work
um with activism in and around Darfur in
Sudan it had a lot of reverberations
past the past just being a movie
Marvel Cinematic Universe the committee
would now like to invite Lieutenant
Colonel James Rhodes to the chamber
roadie
hey buddy
to expect to see you here look it's me
I'm here to deal with it it's famously
known online how you unvived Terence
Howard for the role of rodeo I Aunt vivd
him I did not move Terence out of a role
he was not they had decided that they
weren't that was not happening and it
was an open part
um and I was at my kids laser tag
birthday party and they called me and
said this is what's happening
um we're giving you the offer if you
don't say yes we're going to the next
person this is it has to be this is
going to happen very fast so they said
why don't you go ahead and take an hour
and decide if you want to do it I said
it was a six movie deal I was like in an
hour I have to decide like what are the
other movies they're like it's going to
be these Avengers it's going to be these
many Ironmans this is what it is so you
kind of have to say yes or no if you're
in or out like what's the trajectory of
the character going to be well they're
like we can't we don't know any of that
but
this is what it is so you've got an hour
I said I'm at my kids laser tag birthday
party they're like oh take two hours
take two hours so so we played laser tag
for two hours and I was talking to my
wife and we just kind of thought about
it and talked to my agent and tried to
get as much information as we could and
we just took a flyer and said okay we'll
do it we don't have to do this Tony you
want to be the war machine took your
shot put it down you're gonna take a
shot put it
take it
I'd done some special effects work
before that and you know acting to
tennis balls on top of a c-stand you
know it's it's a lot to get used to
there's no bigger platform in no bigger
sort of special effects toys and bells
and whistles and stuff than Marvel of
course but ultimately it's you're you're
still ultimately trying to do the same
thing always is create believable
circumstances for your character to step
into inside your own head so that you
believe what it is that you're doing and
then the audience can believe
hopefully the favorite one that I'm
going to do is Roadies movie that'll
we're going to shoot I think in in every
successive film he's coming more and
more out of Tony's Shadow and becoming
his own person but I still think we
haven't really figured out who he is and
really dug into that so that's what the
movie is for it's going to be a series
now we're going to do it as a film
armors so I'm looking forward to that
it's been like 12 years now which is
bananas that you know from that moment
uh till now we've been doing it for so
long and it just it just keeps expanding
and growing and these universes keep you
know folding in on each other and
different characters being introduced
and relationships popping up so I
haven't seen any scripts I don't know
where it's headed but I'm excited about
the potential
the oceans trilogy
I tend to do this job in Reno we're in
Barney
Barney Rubble trouble big Ensemble
everybody had to play their position and
everybody had their specialty I it was a
lot of grinding on an on an accent that
you know I've been both vilified and
praised for all right chefs
[Music]
on to your [ __ ]
nothing was real we weren't really
blowing stuff up I mean sure there were
some pyrotechnics and you know
controlled things most of that stuff was
just you know movie Magic Steven knows
always exactly what it is that he's
gonna do and how he's gonna do it once
we're going you know he has a plan but
he's able to adjust and and move with
the plan when we came back to do the
second film we hadn't seen each other
for a long time we hadn't all been
together we were just reuniting so we
were just Milling around for an hour and
then we realized oh wait we're actually
here to shoot something and we all
stopped and took our attention to Steve
and he was like are you guys all where
you want to be we're like yeah he's like
okay all right go to lunch and we came
back and there were marks on the floor
and Camera positions and lenses and
moves and all different color chalk it
was like a beautiful mind on the floor
he had choreographed the whole scene
you've gone right out of your tree my
son he's mad it's Madness yeah it's
crazy no I love it that the second movie
is the one that people will just
unabashedly walk up to and go yeah I
hated that one that one sucked it's like
cool you just said that to my face like
I'm not a person but all right thank you
but that was actually for us the most
fun of all of them when we're in Italy
we stayed at the darussi hotel we had
the whole sixth floor to ourselves
because we really couldn't go anywhere
you know Paparazzi is an Italian word we
really were kind of sequestered but they
they were able to give us that whole
floor and all of our families were there
so my kids were there and Matt's kids
were there and we'd you know we just
like toured toward Europe with in this
big group and it was just a lot of fun
everybody's had a lot of fun together
Devil in a blue dress
hey you better shoot this song [ __ ]
easy Mouse when we're shooting oh
I had worked with Carl Franklin the
director before he uh done an AFI
project I was in so I came in and I was
just in his head stuck in the same age
that he I was 19 years old to him he was
like you're not Denzel's contemporary
this isn't going to work I'm 10 years
younger than him but uh I came in and
read and he was inspired and had Denzel
come in and I read with Denzel and we
had an instant chemistry and the rest is
just kind of history
when I got a gun in my hand
foreign
got blood on my coat easy
it's a damn expensive coat
well we both you know come from a
theater background and both had very
similar way of working and both really
were interested in creating these
characters and and this relationship and
digging into what our history was and
how we understood each other and the
shorthand that we had obviously I was
impressed and a little intimidated at
first to work with Denzel but once we
got on set and just started doing it was
just a couple of actors coming to work
you just said don't shoot him right
that's right well I didn't I just I
choked it
what
well how am I going to help you out if
I'm if I'm back here fool around with
him now
easy look if you ain't want to kill
why'd you leave him with me that line is
just hilarious that there's a person
who's dead and it's your fault because
you left him with me I mean just the
logic of that I don't know how that
can't be Darkly funny I think you know
it wasn't to play it for Laughs I think
the humor just came out of the
situations in Mouse's perspective on
things which for him was just a matter
of fact logic you know I'm a killer you
leave a dude with a killer he's gonna
kill him like what that's on you kind of
really when you think about it and it
was something that literally we found in
the audition uh it just kind of went
that way and it became something that
just was their relationship
oh look here
now I'll cut you over half because I
know you was too big a fool to take your
chef and that white girl yourself all
right I think that year was kind of a
watershed moment for me that movie did
you know get a lot of attention and a
lot of critical attention so that was
probably for a lot of people where they
became aware of me I had done a lot of
movies uh that year and just started the
ball rolling sort of as a feature actor
Fresh Prince of Bel-Air
[Music]
man I'm just gonna kick back here for a
few days let somebody else do all the
work excuse me young man and this house
everyone carries his own weight
too easy there's a lot of gangster
movies during that time and you know if
you're a young black actor and you could
be in a gangster movie that was a thing
but then there was a lot of people going
like why are these the only kind of
movies that we can do I didn't know any
of them personally it's the first time I
had met them first time I had met Quincy
first time at will obviously I knew he
was a rapper I knew you know his his I
knew him from that world but I didn't
know anything about his acting I thought
the part was going to be fun and and
something just cool to do and you know
just to work with this new Talent who
was super green and was you know
mouthing our lines as we were off camera
you know while he was on camera mouthing
the lines that we were saying so he had
to get up to speed but it was a it was a
lot of fun hi hi
[Applause]
that's the one person actually that I
did know before the show it's fun to
work with your friends
um and it's fun to uh be in an
environment like that where everything
is just like new and popping and we just
had a great time and then after the I
think third day of rehearsal they came
to me and they said you know we want to
um do a show around around you so there
was
um a pilot that we actually shot called
in the house that never went to Air and
it never became so they later kept the
the name it was a completely different
concept and everything you know I wrote
the music for the the intro and all this
stuff and it was going to be on right
after Fresh Prince and so the show went
the way of the dodo bird but that was
that was going to be an interesting sort
of back to back
Boogie Nights
you're not being fair
this isn't fair this financial
institution cannot endorse pornography
pornography why are you doing this
please
I'm sorry Carl Franklin directed uh
Devlin blue dress had met Paul and known
him and said this dude's wild you got to
meet this dude this young cat it's like
he's the most confident cocky dude I've
ever met and he wants to talk to you
about this movie and it was I said
what's the movie and he's like it's
Boogie Nights about the porn industry I
was like oh my parents are still alive I
can't I can't do that and he said how
you should meet him you should meet him
and and and see what you think so we
went to a deli and as advertised he was
very cocky very self-assured it was like
you know this is if you if you say no
you're going to really be disappointed
that you didn't do this so I think you
should I think that's something that you
should do and so I went back into a call
yeah this dude's a trip and he was like
yeah but I really have a good feeling
about him so I just I took a flyer and
said yeah I want to work with him and it
was great we had a great experience
oops
a lot of blood
that was a a crazy scene yeah and I
think Paul just had a very very strong
Vision about how he wanted that moment
played and it's an insane obviously it's
an insane moment but that Focus that
pushed into the money and that push in
the buck and he's like I just want to
see all of your dreams the stereo store
and you know being finally having the
opportunity to be the person that you
want to be and establish yourself and
all of that just communicated in that in
that push and then and in his face he's
drenched with blood and brain matter it
was it was crazy but you know it's the
kind of stuff that Paul's great at I've
been very fortunate to have some great
ones where where these characters are
very full to work with very good
directors who know how to bring that all
to life and create sort of the sandbox
and let you play in it and Paul was very
collaborative although he had very clear
ideas he was open to like how you wanted
to bring stuff in the ways you wanted to
bring stuff so it was just a very
creative and that cast is amazing it's a
lot of just great actors and just a
great environment and so in a movie
unlike any movie I'd ever seen and or
heard of until that time
[Music]
of course Captain Planet
let's Spruce this place a bit huh okay
well the funnier die Team I had done one
of their first drunk histories with Will
Ferrell playing Frederick Douglass and
then on the set of oceans I think all
the guys were talking about you know
what really what we really need and what
really doesn't exist and it's a shame
that it doesn't is a a ball spa for men
so I pitched this ridiculous idea for
sax West was the ball spa and George
Lopez did it instead of the entertainers
in the clip and Ray Romano and Joe
Montana and just Hallie Jones all these
idiots came together to do this thing
and I said okay well while you guys are
doing this stupid one we have this thing
called Captain Planet which we want to
do uh would you like to do it I didn't
know what Captain Planet was they're
like oh he's like Captain planet's
animated he's gonna save the Earth and
you do this all this stuff for the
environment you know you're the Goodwill
and Ambassador for the environment
program he thinks it's a great fit so I
read the thing it made me laugh and I
was like yeah so let's do it so I'm
sitting down in the makeup chair and
they start to come come over with this
blue face paint I was like what's that
they're like well it's Captain Planet
I'm like I don't I don't want to do that
and they're like well this is how
Captain Planet looks and they showed me
the picture of him I was like that's
ridiculous I don't want to do it and I
almost left and they
I don't know how they talked me into
doing it somebody talked me into doing
it so I did it and immediately regretted
it after I did it but then I saw it and
it it made me laugh so I thought it was
pretty funny and now it's ridiculous how
many people talk about that character I
can't let you do this captain
[Music]
foreign
I mean they were just like we what's the
craziest thing how can we end this in
the craziest way that we can so let's
have him be like the good guy you know
and be the guy that would be your hero
on Saturday but he's messed up in his
head that Captain Planet was very messed
up clearly remember turn off the faucet
between usages and recycle those
Plastics or else
I'll turn you into a [ __ ] tree
Captain Planet [ __ ]
crash
in L.A nobody touches you
we're always behind this metal and glass
I think we missed that touch so much
to be crash into each other just so we
can feel something he's a very cynical a
character and a very seemingly you know
disaffected and and and and burnt out
kind of a kind of a cop who has a mother
that is very disappointed in drug addict
you know a brother who's a criminal like
he's just in this broken family the dad
in around he's a very broken dude I
believe I promise you I promise I'm
gonna find out who did this Mom
oh I already know
you did one of the best moments for that
character in that movie is after his
brother is is killed after he discovers
that his brother's killed and has gone
to his house his mother's house you know
prior to that and bought all the food
and brought all the groceries that she
says you know as there's as they're in
the morgue you know the last thing your
brother did was brought me groceries it
was the last thing he did like he's
saying to him like he was the good kid
and you're the bad kid and that he
doesn't correct her and he just takes it
and it just gets broken some more
came home
[Music]
he brought me groceries
it was a tragic character and the movie
I think a lot of people had a problem
with that movie because they sort of
took it they I think they missed the
broader point of the movie in some ways
which is in my opinion not to be taken
as literal and in some ways is more
allegorical and a lot of what if and
sort of sliding doors situations with
these characters bumping into each
other's lives and crashing into each
other's lives in these ways yeah another
great ensemble cast low budget you know
grind one of those movies that you show
up because you just want to tell the
story it's not about let's all get paid
it was you know just really really good
cast and really solid filmmaking traffic
sure I can't offer you something to
drink I can offer you a joke you wanna
hear a joke I got it I got it I got a
joke I got a joke come on bro it's just
a joke let me tell one joke I'm gonna
tell you a joke okay all right
why a hurricane named after woman
I don't know because when they arrived
they're wet and wild when they leave
they take your house and your car
again amazing director Stephen
Soderbergh he called me and said I've
got this other movie I'm gonna do it's
not exactly a triptych but it was kind
of three you know different uh looks at
the at the drug trafficking it was based
on a UK series and he's just like I want
you and I just see you in Luis Guzman
and his Partners three different styles
visual Styles bridging that all together
having these characters move in and out
of each other's lives it was just really
a a cool experience another really cool
experience with a lot of great actors
and Louise and I you know became really
good friends after that and still
registered lives today at the whispering
the whispering alone you can't hear it I
love the [ __ ] bugs too far away from
the room man I told you it's halfway to
the kitchen We're not gonna get [ __ ]
they're saying something
sounds like they're conspiring to
conspire
you know I could feel the lies vibrating
from that home
I don't think she's in on it man
come on I dream about this I have actual
dreams about this about busting the top
people the rich people white people I
know one of the joys of the job is that
we get to learn a lot about a lot of
different things when we get to inhabit
a lot of different characters and and
get to kind of stay in school you know
get to always be a student of people and
a student of of different genres and
just a student of the crap it's one of
the most fun things about the gig
getting to play make-believe and things
that we were doing is that we all did as
kids right but with the best toys and
the best circumstances and best props
and best other play actors playing
around you so it's always it's always
something to look forward to and why the
job just never gets old
that are coming this way
foreign
[Music]
if you look at the scene where Louise's
character is killed it doesn't make any
sense on film there's two blocks you can
use the fresh air you know I've been
stuck in that piece of [ __ ] hotel room
for two weeks
I'm gonna walk because I wanna walk
okay it's emotional my character is
destroyed he's lost his partner this
scene doesn't make any sense
but you are with those characters and
you want you're invested in the
characters you're invested in their
emotional in their emotions you're
invested in the story or mess invested
in their Journey so I've I you know I
when I ask people about that scene
nobody's ever bad at an eyelash when I
go through it they're like oh yeah that
doesn't make any sense and I said yeah
and I talked to Stephen about it and he
said right it just goes to show you if
you've earned the audience you know you
can do a lot because they just they're
invested in the characters
why noise
no just very interesting movies and this
is a huge departure from the kind of
movie that Noah does both in size and
scope except for sort of the
interpersonal character Dynamics and
still it's a movie about characters and
about relationships but it's wrapped
what's it's wrapped in is this huge big
dramatic undertaking of this event that
is happening that is impacting the
gladney family and ever all the
residents of this town what happened
katsakis my rival is
no longer in the land of the living He
said
lost in the surf off Malibu it's a farce
about death you know I think it's really
is what it is is a commentary about our
inability to control our circumstances
and at a time like today it's a very
interesting time to to have this film
come out amid elections and covid and
the Supreme Court and January 6th I mean
everything is just sort of looming and
making us have to deal with over and
over and over again the shifting Sands
under our feet I think it's a very
timely moment for this movie to come out
now I have a feeling about mothers
mothers really do know
the folklore is correct Hitler adored
his mother
he was the first of Clara's children to
survive infancy
Elvis and Gladys like to nuzzle and pet
they slept in the same bed until he
began to approach physical maturity they
talked baby talk to each other Hitler
was a lazy kid
his report card was full of
unsatisfactories Gladys worried about
his sleepwalking she lashed out at any
kid who would bully him
Gladys walked Elvis to school and back
every day she defended him in Street
Rumble but Clara loved him so David and
Adam and Noah and myself kind of just
worked that moment out we knew that we
wanted it to be like a performance piece
that it wasn't just going to be two
professors lecturing we wanted it to
feel like a duel we wanted to feel like
a dance we wanted to feel like some big
moment that for Murray my character
specifically wanted to sort of bring
more attention to himself and and bring
some sort of dynamism to his lecture his
Elvis lecture that he needed to like
work in a little Hitler to like really
spice it up the supermarket is a waiting
place it recharges us spiritually it's a
Gateway look how bright look how full of
psychic data waves and radiation all the
letters and numbers are here all the
colors of the spectrum all the voices
and sounds all the code words and
ceremonial phrases the supermarket is
the place where you know you want to
fight for a normalcy and I think it's
it's a real commentary on like you said
consumerism in some gross ways you know
our desire to have instantaneous comfort
and immediate calming effect on us this
is a very American concept it doesn't
exist in most places around the world in
the ridiculous amount in the ridiculous
way that it exists here but it's also uh
I think the movie is kind of a love
letter to the 80s and a love letter to
80s filmmaking in many ways and you know
sort of Spielberg kind of feel in some
ways it's got a lot of different genres
that it's incorporating in this movie so
it's a big it's a big swing no it took a
really big swing and I think it's kind
of expansive and really fun